like soldiers on the battlefield the
nation's first responders can experience
extreme stress a routine part of their
jobs and those encounters take a toll
well one woman saw the problem and found
a unique way to help her nonprofit yoga
for the first responders teaches mental
physical and emotional resilience
through the practice of yoga Barry
Petersen shows us how it's helping our
heroes when crisis strikes Superman is
the ultimate first responder he is
always calm and that is yoga lesson one
for real first responders you don't see
his shoulders up and you don't see this
short fast breath no matter what's going
on Superman has the chest up and is calm
breathing and that's representative of
power you'll find yoga teacher Olivia
Meade with unusual students firefighters
in full gear trainees to become
sheriff's deputies in Denver Colorado so
we have to stay focused and concentrated
in this moment to be ready for anything
they are learning the Superman lesson
control your breathing to stay calm and
you stay in control when you're in a
threat response where your survival is
at stake you're not always making the
best or most accurate decisions you're
just trying to survive
Olivia founded a nonprofit called yoga
for first responders and Criss crosses
the country teaching yoga to police and
firefighters inhale drop it out ha you
know how to grab your weapon you know
how to talk to people you know how to
use your body same thing with the yoga
it's going to happen automatically
because you've trained for it beforehand
this is now a mandatory class at the
training academy from Denver County
sheriff's deputies deputies who work in
the jail's are unarmed dealing with
prisoners who may have mental health
drug problems or be angry about being in
jail trouble explodes
says Denver County Sheriff Patrick
Furman it may be inmates fighting with
one another it may be an inmate going
through crisis that they've got to
somehow interact with and intervene with
how important is calm when you're
dealing with this it's critical I mean
you know if you go into a crisis
situation and you're not calm you're
gonna you're gonna escalate that
situation there is another need once the
fire is out of the SWAT team is finished
first responders must deal with what
they saw and did for that yoga can be a
vital alternative says captain Anthony
getler who commands the training academy
so there has to be a way for them to
process that stress when you control the
breath you're controlling your mind and
to be able to decompress without using
other means or alcohol in this line of
work there's alcoholism and and there's
high suicide rates so we want to give
people a different alternative is there
a preventative quality to yoga for these
first responders yes and I think
practicing it proactively is where we're
most effective that's why I love
teaching in the academy which means what
they master now may pay off for years to
come for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen Denver Oh fantastic yeah I mean
I I am a yoga believer just in my own
life I've seen how breathing makes such
a difference and even if you don't
believe in anything else in the practice
you can figure that part out it makes
such a difference it is such a huge
problem the mental state of first
responders I did my master's thesis on
that subject the fact that they found
something to help is just for men
something without using a drug without
anything else yeah about the breathing
right yeah